sois said i'm gonna do a talk for sap
it'll be slides and then hopefully we'll
get two demos at the end but the overall
theme of this is getting access to large
repositories of remote sensing and
weather data stuff that's too big to fit
on a single machine by far but being
able to analyze it with the jupiter
notebooks so a little bit about my
background I've been at Google about
five years and some people do ask me
like what was your path to Google sounds
like you have a good job well this is
what I did for a number of years for
four years to be specific it's when
around the backcountry
digging snow pits sampling snow for a
lack of better looking at grain size
freezing my fingers off and clean wrong
with electronics but it gave me
appreciation of how environmental data
is really messy and valuable and hard to
collect and so basically I've dedicated
my my career to building more technology
tools that will allow people to leverage
the environmental data that is being
collected around the world the other hat
that I have on Google in addition to
supporting those type of environment use
cases is being a supporter of Google's
Python interfaces for Earth engine the
project I'll be talking about in the
past I've been active in the free and
open-source for software for geospatial
software foundation meetings helped host
the international conference in Denver
in 2011 mostly at that point focused on
academic uses of Python and also have
authored some libraries that are useful
for manipulating the spatial data Python
this one's called pykml but what I'm
going to talk about today is a project
that we have at Google called Earth
engine and it came out of google.org the
main thrust of it was to give get into
the hands of groups around the world
tools that will help them monitor and
hopefully improve the environment that
is being degraded there's a lot of great
technological advances that are going on
in the world but at the same time
there's a lot of resource depletion
that's going on this is
a shot of looking in Google Earth of the
Brazilian Amazon and you can see the
intensive deforestation that's going on
in the foreground where you can see some
of the protected areas in the background
and this still progresses at a rapid
rate around the world and it's hard to
get a handle on and it's hard to really
connect with people for them to
understand without seeing the the scale
of it you can talk about you know how
many millions or hundreds of millions of
acres are being deforested but it's
really powerful to actually see that in
in real time using things like the NASA
earth science data that's being
collected by a series of satellite
that's up there it's not just NASA it's
NOAA it's agencies from other countries
like European Union or the European
Space Agency has a lot of satellites up
there they're all observing the earth
this has been happening for the last 40
years continuously but it tends to be
very large in a sense data in terms of
volumes especially if you're trying to
pull it locally it also tends to be
really messy data because you have
things like the the atmosphere going on
and the sensor is degrade and it's
really hard to get up into space and fix
a spacecraft because so once it starts
going bad you don't throw it away just
learn to work with the be quirky data
that comes out of it
just to give you an example of the scale
here is one example satellite that the
usgs currently manages it's called
Landsat and there's been a series of
these satellites seven of them over the
last 40 years they collect pretty much
on the ground on a 30 meter pixel size
so the size of a baseball
infield roughly over a width of 180
kilometers and as they are acquiring
data it happens to be a rate of about a
half a terabyte every 45 seconds that's
kind of their unit of block that they
usually distribute the data called the
scene so that takes 45 seconds to get a
half a terabyte of data so at this point
in my talk you've already probably well
beyond filled up your hard drive you
know with just the data that's being
collected by one of these satellites in
there does
that are going on and have been going on
for 40 years so it's a lot of data in
some sense at the other hand it's
actually a really sparse amount of data
that these satellites don't revisit
every point in the earth all the time
you might get a seen in case of Landsat
like every 16 days for a signal single
point under it so it's really sparse and
it's really blue - at the same time what
these agencies have done in the past is
take all that data that's downloaded
from satellite and sit it on a tape and
put it in a vault somewhere this is the
arrow status Center that's in South
Dakota and they have gotten better in
the last few years that more of the
recent data that's being acquired from
the satellite will be directly available
through some type of web service or as a
file download but it still stands to be
a huge volume of data even though they
are getting into online so we're trying
to make that easier to work with Earth
engine and as an overview of what -
Earth engine is its self it combines
three aspects one is just large storage
that we have at Google we're gonna
download that raw data and put it
available on spinning disk we're gonna
put algorithms that understand
geospatial data like projections and
where this data was collected on earth
and then also collate co-located with a
lot of CPUs for computation so Earth
engine is basically customized to
Rubio's geospatial data it's a cloud API
and we have we have two api's right now
a Python and a JavaScript API but the
thrust of this talk is how do you get
that to communicate with something like
Jupiter which has been you know a
powerful project that been really
revolutionary in kind of data science
but hasn't been applied that often to
geospatial datasets so this is kind of
what I'm gonna get to I'm gonna talk
about throughout this talk all the
different components of it but is
hooking up Jupiter as the front end on
one end using AI PI widgets and some
specialized versions of I PI widgets to
talk to a Python kernel and then that
Python kernel akin communicates into the
cloud to earth engine to grab geospatial
data and instruct it on how to analyze
it as well
alright so Earth engine has said it's
basically it's Google's cloud platform
our
our goal in general at Google is to
organize the world's information earth
engine's goal is just to do this for
geospatial kind of a subset of the
world's information and just make it
useful you know or this always comes up
kind of later on but I'll start off with
it it's just it's not an open API in
terms that you get need to get
whitelisted but our whitelisting process
is really easy you fill out a form with
about four boxes and you then get an
email with access to it the reason that
we do whitelisting is that we give you a
very powerful API where you have the
ability to summarize all of the world's
data down into a single point and that
may cause havoc for other users so if
you do that so if you have any
problematic queries we can at least
identify shut down to user talk with
them figure out what they're trying to
do so they don't impact other users the
default Terms of Service allow for
development of research educational
purposes people are publishing papers in
like science in nature just under our
standard Terms of Service we also have a
commercial terms of service which is
custom for commercial use cases but that
tends to be a really small percentage of
our users most of our users are academic
or government researchers NGOs
nonprofits around the world groups like
that that are trying to to make a
difference and that's where our support
efforts lie as well so what can you do
with earth engine one thing that we've
done within Earth engine is produced the
cloud free base map that you see in
Google Maps or Google Earth this is
based on Landsat and Sentinel 2 imagery
as the sources and we just composited
data over the number of years looking
for the cleanest pixels so we can get a
cloud free base map of the world so we
use it internally and we reuse in our
consumer products we also produce these
things like videos of the entire earth
here's just a small portion of that
video I mean the video and in terms in
size that's it's the entire Earth at 30
meter resolution but this is Las Vegas
and you can see over the course of you
know like three decades the growth of
the city and the depletion of the lake
they're not necessarily correlated
directly they just happen to be next to
each other and it makes for a
visualization but this type of video on
a yearly time step is available
throughout the entire world if you want
to go look at this fourth engine
time-lapse it's kind of a neat way to
get at least an idea of what satellite
data is available and what things
changes are going on at the Earth's
surface but it's also used in addition
for those visualizations for deriving
important information about change in
our earth in 2013 we had a paper in
science magazine with co-authors from
the University of Maryland that were
looking at the yearly change in forest
cover throughout the entire world so we
can get accurate statistics on where
deforestation is happening where
regrowth is happening is it getting
better as it getting worse etc so that
was a kind of an academic building
knowledge activity for attention and
that was later used by a bunch of NGOs
to start doing kind of monitoring and
you know build awareness around
consumers of their use here's another
one which we've looked at on a monthly
time scale where water has occurred on
the surface of Earth so you can see like
braided rivers migrating dams going in
wetlands being destroyed cetera things
like that it's a really valuable record
the Earth's surface and how do we do
that
once again we have three main components
of it it's the data the algorithms and
the storage for engine and then we have
an API that just sits around and waits
for requests for using applying
algorithms that data and returns results
the results that come out of Earth
engine tend to be for the most part
really small relative the data sets
inside so you might get like a PNG
representation that shows you you know a
land cover rather than having to
download the raw data so it's orders of
magnitude faster than trying to do the
download yourself which has been the
typical paradigm in earth sciences for a
long time is order the data download it
do the analysis locally and that's just
slow or impatient about making change in
the world
so what data do we have in there I
talked already about the Landsat
collection that's our largest collection
by right now it goes back 40 years we
also have
other data sets that have different
spectral temporal spatial
characteristics modus is another sensor
that the US government puts out NASA
maintains that we have terrain data we
have land cover data we have atmospheric
data we have weather climate forecast
for the future etc we're really driven
by what our end users want us to put
into Earth engine and we prioritize
based on their requests so it's not a
complete archive it's basically a mirror
of useful data sets then that's somebody
hasn't determined to be useful
we set up feeds so that we get ingestion
on a nightly basis we get on the order
of four thousand five thousand new
images each night as the data providers
make them available in addition we have
a lot of the operators that you might
find in a GIS or a remote sensing
package a ways to manipulate images
collections of images features which are
vectors polygons points etc we have
things like sequel like joins within
there we have in dimensional
representations so you do the linear
algebra within Earth engine basically a
lot of building blocks that people can
chain together to make a more complex
algorithm that works on this type of
spatial data also I have machine
learning algorithms that are integrated
within the system and we have a lot of
computers ague so we put it there
so we have two api's for this career I
would imagine that the Python API is
more of interest and is important to
understand that Earth engine behind the
scenes behind the API doesn't know
anything about Python so you can't run
numpy at scale on Earth engine
it's basically earth or the Python API
is used to construct in pre process
instructions that are going to go to
earth engine and also to interpret the
results so that's like it allows you to
do a lot of things and it prevents you
from doing some things that you really
wanted to do you have to often translate
the algorithms that you might have in
something like numpy into earthen
engines primitives in order to get it to
work but the things that people have
been able to do with that are pretty
impressive I'm gonna just gave a few
example here map of life and climate
engine and actually this one dealt ours
aqua monitor they produce these
interactive maps of the world
with their own custom user interface you
know sliders and then this one allows
you to select two years over the last
thirty years and just compare where
water has been gained or lost throughout
the world you can see a lot of changes
going on for instance in India Aral Sea
has dried up during that time etc allows
you to just interact with the data sets
here's another one where people have
been using Earth engine to monitor
species around the world just where are
where is their range how is it changing
it's called a map of life and then a
last one here is a interface that's more
for academic scientists that are looking
at drought and and weather changes
things like that so let's see so anyway
you can the idea is that we have an API
and then people build front ends on it
using typical web technologies most of
the time you know we're not involved at
this this level of building it that's an
expertise that's outside of what our
team focuses on but a lot of groups have
it have that expertise in-house to build
these complex websites that then can
access the environmental data in their
attention all right so what tools are
used to develop these algorithms
well we maintain something that we call
the playground or code editor and it's
an IDE that allows you to manage scripts
display results on the maps there's
charting within their kind of a code
editor in there an inspector for
clicking around and figuring out what
your data values are at different points
in space and time but the whole problem
that I see with this is that you have to
write in JavaScript in order to use it
so that is a big barrier to a lot of the
scientific users that have gone to that
I think it's kind of crazy to be working
with large months of scientific data and
JavaScript but remember that behind the
scenes Earth engine doesn't know
anything about JavaScript or Python API
itself so you get the same functionality
in JavaScript that you wouldn't python
and we just found that it's easier to
host in in keep I guess manage a
he that allows people to do JavaScript
programming but I realize that a lot of
the people that are using earth engine
when they build their own website that
use the Python API because they can use
the Python web frameworks in order to
create these websites so we have this
little bit of disconnect here is that
people are developing algorithms using
our IDE and then they have to do a
little translation to Python API in
order to get it running on their own
website outside of our IDE so that's a
little bit problematic so I think that a
solution for this which is really in the
early stages at this point is to use
Jupiter as that front-end for developing
the algorithms and so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the components that I
think will make this useful I'm gonna be
showing you a bit about Jupiter but more
specifically I'm going to be using
Jupiter lab which is the next generation
user interface for the Jupiter project
I'm assuming that everybody at this
point coming to PI data would probably
have heard of Jupiter at this point the
front end they have a new front-end
called Jupiter lab that is more like an
integrated IDE is just not just the
Jupiter notebooks but it has a lot of
other things its current status is that
it's either pre alpha or beta I'm not
sure the exact designation but I've
heard that it's ready for the
adventurous and we're gonna be
adventurous with us and think that it
will stabilize in the next few months
the other key component that I'm using
is Jupiter widgets and these are what
allow the Jupiter front-end to talk to
Python behind the scenes and talk back
and forth it's not just a one mate
communication so an example of this is
if you want to have a widget that allows
you to select a number down here like
I'm gonna select 42 I then can query it
for the value and I actually I guess I
captured this after I move my thing
around so 42 doesn't match up exactly
with the zero they should if I actually
ran that cell and then a very specific
widget that I have been making use of is
I PI leaflet which wraps the leaflets
JavaScript library for interactive
mapping I PI leaflet is maintained by
some of the core developers of Jupiter
so I think that it will be around here
to stay it's actually pretty powerful
even in its early stages right now
making use of that and once again this
is kind of
the setup that we have here so front end
with their JavaScript controls the
widgets they'll talk to the backend the
Python kernel and that Python kernel
then can talk to earth engine through
our Python API and to make this easy
because there is some setup involved I
created a docker container that actually
will make this front-end for you so I'll
have links to that at the end of the end
of the talk if you're interested in that
docker container alright demo time I got
20 minutes alright so I'm gonna start
off here with actually let me close out
of here for a second and make this
a little larger but it went off screen
here all right there we go all right so
to start up there's a docker run command
sorry about that if it's still too small
all right so there is a docker run
command here at the bottom that it's
it's just setting up in running this
Saipan notebook with Jupiter lab and
Earth engine installed the thing that I
have made available there on github and
it's mapping a bunch of ports from my
local machine you could run this leh
locally like I'm doing you could run in
the cloud you could separate the kernel
from the front-end etc there's all kinds
of different ways to set it up but just
for demonstrations here I'm gonna run it
locally and so I'm gonna fire that up
and when I do get here I get my cursor
back is a URL we're starting Jupiter
kernel I'll go over here and just
rebased it into my browser
as well and at this point I now have you
know a file explorer with bunch of files
as I said there's a docker file in here
if you're curious for you know how this
was created so basically it installs or
it takes a jupiter-sized notebook this
is a docker container that's maintained
by the Jupiter project that has a lot of
the scientific Python libraries in it
and then it's gonna add a few things to
it I'm adding I PI widgets and then
going down a little bit farther I'm
adding a plotting more I bread called BK
pots I'm not going to talk much about
that but there in the next session I
noticed that there's actually a talk
coming up on VK of a plot and then
eventually down here I PI leaflet and
Earth engine so this should give you
instructions on how to get it set up
if you're curious if I'm doing it in a
docker container or even not in a docker
container and then also within here I
have a notebook that's called satellite
analysis and let me make myself a little
bit more room here and we'll start
running through it okay so just to make
make sure I'm being honest here I'm
gonna clear all the outputs and restart
the kernel but we just started up so
that was pretty unnecessary and run this
first one and the first thing I get is
this error which is intentional it's not
a bad thing right now and it just says
that you're not authenticated to Earth
engine but the nice thing about this is
that we have little instructions here on
how to authenticate to Earth engine so
I'm just going to copy that Earth engine
authenticated command and then I can go
back here and open up a terminal in
Jupiter and I'm gonna run that on you
know the kernel that's running which
happens to be in my laptop here and all
it gives you back is a URL that you can
use for authentication so I'm going to
go to that URL and it says you know
choose your accounts give it certain
permissions which is to manage cloud
storage so we can store things in the
cloud and then all
so to access earth engine sounds good to
me gives me back a little 10 occation
code which I then can paste into here
into the terminal and it says it's
successfully saved it now if I go back
to my first command here for my initial
setup and run it I no longer get the
error and I'm importing a bunch of
Python libraries up here that I'm gonna
use later and then the last command
there is kind of key it says EE
initialized and that says the Python the
Earth engine library is going to go talk
to the server and figure out what it can
do today so by itself the Python API
doesn't know what it can do until it it
asks you know what objects and what
methods are available and there will be
about a thousand of them that are
returned once it's initialized so then
the library is populated going down a
little further you can do things nice
things in ipython like display webpages
so I just displayed the web page that we
have describing one of our data sets on
Landsat 8 surface reflectance it's
basically a measure of how much light
should reflect off the surface even
though that's not directly with the
satellite measures that's something that
the USGS puts out as a data product a
key point that's within here is that
there is a image collection ID down here
and it's lower right at this point that
is how you can refer to all the images
in that collection so you do you
basically refer to it as a single object
and that's the next line down here I'm
gonna say I have a variable called l8 SR
which is a Landsat image collection and
if you're curious about how many images
are in there there's a command called
size so if I just run that for a little
bit
you will notice also if you look closely
at my Python code here there is a lot of
get infos and that just means go talk to
the server and request stuff back you
can construct a lot of instructions in
Earth engine without actually going in
getting them and executing them so it's
not until I say get info will attack
go back and say give me what the the
underlying did is so at this point we
got about six hundred and fifty thousand
images that are in that collection and
just to show you a little bit of what
happens if you don't use get in full
this is kind of the language that gets
sent back to earth engine it's like it's
a requesting a number that is indicating
collection size that function on the
Landsat image collection so you know
this is kind of what's going on
underneath the hood in order to request
the size of a collection alright so now
that we know a little bit more about the
size of the collection we can do things
like pull out a single image from there
I have I'm starting with that Landsat
eight collection LasR I'm filtering it
first by date and then by location the
location I put in there is New York City
so we're gonna get just the scenes that
are over City and then requesting you
know the first image in that collection
from that really small time period I
basically have this month in terms of a
time period and then once that image
comes back I can say what band names
which are the different channels that
the satellite was looking at we got
basically about twelve or so of these
bands some of them are spectral
responses and other ones are referring
to the quality of the the data whether
there's clouds or not for example what
I'm gonna do now is rename all of those
bands b1 b2 b3 to be more human readable
in terms of what they're looking at
for example the b2 is the blue channel
of the visible light etc so I'll do that
here and then what we then can do is
print out you know metadata on that
entire image and at this point you know
it's a lot of just text metadata but it
talks about you know what is the
projection of the image how does it sit
on the earth what are the dimensions of
it and basically what part of the
spectrum you know the idea of the
channel all of that is included within
here a lot of information that's just in
the metadata and if you get down all the
way to the end you get some metadata
that was provided by the
original provider like what does the
cloud cover what is the distance the Sun
all this stuff you might want to use in
your Python algorithms you know to
interpret the data correctly it's all
there if you need it but it's not very
visual so next thing I'm gonna do here
is say get me a thumbnail URL for this
particular image using the bounds of the
image and if I do that and click on it
here we get like a nice PNG image it's
pretty small you know it's requesting
back just a representation of that image
and then the nice thing is that you can
also do this within the jupiter notebook
like i can request that image URL it's
not interactive you know i can't click
and drag and move it around but at least
gives you an overview of what that
single image is remember it could be on
the order of half a terabyte if you
wanted to download this and start
working with it yourself but anyway that
non interactive view is only so nice so
let's go and do use some of these
widgets for interactive viewing so I'm
gonna start using the eye pie leaflet
module here right now to create a map at
a certain zoom level this map is now
interactive you know I can move it
around like this I also have some
drawing tools on here so if I was
curious about you know identifying some
area in South America I could actually
do that as well and the nice thing about
this is once I draw on the map you know
in the front end the Python kernel now
knows about it I can say for my drawing
command you know what was the last draw
command what did it do and it basically
created this geometry with these certain
coordinates etc and once again you can
use that in your in your later code in
the notebook which is pretty powerful
all right so let's do a few more things
I'm going to use a function here that
knows how to construct a request to
Earth engine for a tile in the form that
this I PI leaflet understands so this is
you know four lines basically connecting
the two things together and then I will
use that tile URL that I constructed to
add a layer to the map so let me go back
up here to the map and I'm gonna zoom
out a little bit and go find you know
it's basically Where's Waldo
in the world I can go find that image
for New York City and now it's at least
you have a frame of reference of where
was and and this is a really cloudy
image but that's that's life that's
typical for these satellites it's pretty
rare that you get really clear ones
especially in for an LA cloudy areas so
you have to do the best that you can
with this type of information all right
so oK we've got an image let's check our
time here and the next step down here
then is to get rid of a little bit of
that filtering that I did on the image
collection so if you remember earlier I
filtered it down to a particular month
and then pick the first image in there
so I filtered it down to one image but
in this case I'm gonna run a query that
instead of doing one day let's expand it
out to like a week maybe and once you
get back that collection I can run a
aggregation on it like take the median
value of the images if they're
overlapping because these satellite
paths do overlap especially if you
expand out in time let me run that and
as I move back up here you'll start
seeing you know how many images were
collected for a particular week and the
nice thing about this is I can you know
start panning around to wherever I want
in the world and the only time the data
is being requested is that when it comes
in to the viewpoint so it's loading a
really small subset of that potential
you know multi terabytes to petabyte of
data in there probably you know for that
small time period it's not going to be
anywhere near petabyte but if you are
feeling very adventurous then you could
say something like hey let's go back and
do a full year's worth of data here
approximately a year let's do that run
it again here and now you're gonna start
seeing you know take a little bit longer
because in any point in on earth it's
going to be around 25 images
in a year for this particular sensor but
it can gather all those together and
start aggregating them as I said before
the aggregation that we're doing right
now for that stack is called a median
composite so it's like ranking all the
values and then just taking the median
value but we also have other ones like
min and Max mean they actually just do
the point of reference here we're gonna
find a go to Texas where it's sort of
cloudy let it load up here again a
little bit and then I'm going to change
the filter it's from median to be a max
filter and that one actually isn't all
that useful most of the time because
it's a cloud detector anytime there was
a cloud in the year it is now being
shown so not too useful you know
possible but not very useful you can
also do the opposite you can do the
minimum value over the course of the
year and this one actually tends to look
okay when you're zoomed out it's kind of
dark
because it's the minimum value but if
you zoom in then you start seeing these
pock marks which are try to show a few
of them here all these dark things those
are cloud shadows so it's not actually
really that good either
okay if I'm this hot but there's all
kinds of different ways you can do
reductions the one I'm gonna next do now
here is called a percentile reducer so
it's gonna take the twenty-fifth
percents to comment about all the other
reducers I'm not gonna use and run it
again okay all the other ones that I
have here and now it's it's gonna give
you you know the 25th percentile which
actually looks pretty decent in many
areas when you zoom around because it
gets rid of the shadows on the low end
and then also some of the clouds on the
top end alright so that's how to access
a lot of data pretty quickly the other
things you can do is actually do BAM
manipulation so instead of looking at
particular bands I might want to you
know combine different spectral channels
I'm gonna actually if we're looking at
the electromagnetic spectrum here and
all these blocks are
landsat collects data I'm gonna take a
block v ban Phi which is near-infrared
and normalize it by the red channel
which is block four there and the way
that you express that in Jupiter no
bobasa's
and do it mathematically which is
totally nice unlike some other
interfaces but I basically can write a
command and as well you know five lines
a pretty verver skoda that just says hey
select the red select the near-infrared
normalize them together and then add
that back to my image stack and then at
this point I have a NDVI band which I
then can start displaying go back and
I'm gonna go somewhere where you know
what the NDVI looks like which is
Central Valley of California
and once you do this you start getting
the these maps that show you kind of the
variation in vegetation health so dark
areas are going to be not that much of
Education that might be barren there
might be cities etc the bright green
ones are where they have active like
agriculture going on over the course of
the year and it's taking the maximum
value so that's just a way to get like a
simple derived kind of indicee and the
last thing I'm going to do is chain a
lot more of these widgets together to
make something that's even a little bit
more interesting based on all these
little components that I've described so
far and what I'm going to show you here
if I can get it all to fit on the screen
is first a interactive map that lets say
we go back to California again
zoom into California and then I'm going
to drop a little marker here somewhere
in the Central Valley where I know
there's agriculture going on and what
this does once I drop that value is it's
gonna go sample all of the Landsat 8
data for from 2008 13 to present and
this is the variation of that NDVI value
where I dropped the point here and then
to to kind of see if I can actually go
find I can also drag on the bottom to
identify a time period in this BK plots
plot and it will then go back and
request all of the imagery that was
associated with that time period there
and if I go in let me clear the signal I
had here and I'm gonna drop it on a
particular field to be a little bit more
precise it's gonna redraw the what we
have down there at the bottom and then
what I can do is actually to refresh
right there but anyway you can then
change the time period this type of
interaction where you're getting stuff
back in the front end and being able to
manipulate all of the different
variables that go into remote sensing
analysis is really powerful
I could see interfaces where you might
want to choose the band combinations you
might want to compare two things over
time to see how they're changing all
that should be very possible to build
with the eye pie widgets and the
associated that are within here so
anyway that is a little bit of the demo
all of those available in that docker
container as I said and if we go back to
the last slide here the reason we're
doing this once again is to address like
these big global issues that can be
addressed through remote sensing we
don't always need the participation you
know of people collecting data on the
ground in order to get an observation if
we can use remote sensing there's a lot
of these United Nations sustainable
development goals that can be answered
through this kind of remote remote
sensing monitoring so these are a lot of
things that my team is working on along
with external partners that have more
domain expertise
and then don't need to copy this all
down if you just get the link for this
but I just want to point out that I'm
gonna have the links to the code in in
some of the key websites for the
technology is amusing here and then
finally the summary of this is that
Earth Observation data is getting a lot
easier to use if you were combining
these Jupiter widgets with Earth engine
it gives you even easier access to a lot
of this data in a Python framework and
there are so many different issues
around the world that could use people's
that have skills in this area to help
interpret the data and so we can bring
more awareness the changes that are
going on in the world this final link at
the bottom is this presentation that I
have right here so if you want any of
the resources or a copy to it I just go
to that URL Thanks
[Applause]
so the question is or as an observation
that most of the stuff I was showing is
just in the visible bands red green and
blue did a little bit with the
near-infrared
but these satellites do collect a lot
more information Landsat itself has two
bands in the shortwave infrared there's
a thermal band there there's one that's
just sensitive to like high clouds and
some of the other sensors like modis or
some of the ones from the European Space
Agency they might have 30 or more bands
that are sensitive to different parts of
the electromagnetic spectrum it totally
depends on what you're interested in
monitoring which bands you're going to
pick the ones that are really really
useful though are the thermal bands
which tell you a little bit about the
temperature of the earth because I can
give you an idea of the energy balance I
do a lot of work with people that are
trying to monitor water use by
agricultural crops and getting an idea
of the thermal signature of those fields
is really important for us mating and
how much water is being used
so the question is whether earth engine
has access to high-resolution imagery
from a technical standpoint yes from a
licensing standpoint not usually there
is some data from USDA FSA it's called
nape data which is that one meter
resolution that's available for the
United States on like a three-year
rotating cycle internally we use it for
some of our data that we collect but
that's not necessarily public data let
me think
but the other data providers are putting
out like DMS des live from right lidar
which might be half a meter or
resolution or so so it's totally
dependent on the data source not really
earth engine and so it's basically what
you can already get available publicly
at high resolution we can get into Earth
engine I didn't point out when I was
talking there but there is a way to
upload your own imagery too if you don't
see it in Earth engine and you have a
license to your own high-resolution
commercial imagery you can upload it and
work with it yourself and it's not
shared with others unless you choose to
share it there are some quotas in there
if you look through the documentation
there is a page that is basically limits
or quotas the limits have to do with how
many queries per second you can have how
much storage that you can upload we give
250 gigs currently as a default to just
anybody who signs up in terms of
uploading imagery and then there's also
a limit on large aggregations so very
expensive aggregations we limit how many
you can concurrently do at one time but
that's all described on there's a page
that says limits over Earth engine and
we just adjust those accordingly as we
need to and we also adjust the backend
like how many servers and stuff that we
need depending on how many users we have
[Applause]